[Musique]
une invitation à la danse une certaine
séduction avec nombres et les étoiles le
spectateur plonge dans les ballades ses
poèmes des troubadours et d'être ouvert
les 12e et 13e siècles
j'ai eu envie de rencontrer cette
littérature et aussi cette musique
puisque à l'époque
en fait le poète est aussi musicien la
poésie ne se lit pas elle ne se dit pas
elle se chante c'est une musique et
littérature que je connaissais pas du
tout il ya 4 5 ans et puis et puis on a
envie de d'une sorte d' une sorte d'
endroit lointain d'une espèce de bulle
un peu poétique comme ça
oh
un amour courtois qui se vit au loin les
danseurs accompagnés de l'ensemble alla
francesca déambuler tournoi sans cesse
pour un minimalisme poétique sur ce
spectacle en fait j'ai travaillé avec
avec les danseurs sur le fait que tous
les mouvements devaient être relié à la
rythmicité d'un verre dont syllabes vain
mot donc on est complètement rythmée par
par le par le poème en fait et la
gestuelle est né de cette accumulation
de rythme différent à l'intérieur des
corps
des instants havre de paix entrecoupé de
moments plus fort comme un amour
bouillonnant qui ne demande qu'à être
exprimés